I made one of my favorites of all times
a classic Malaysian breakfast
I just filled water up to the soft boil
Mark and then let the eggs steam until I
hear this music
that's when you know it's done the
consistency was perfect it was exactly
what I was going for
to go with my eggs I made Kaya toast I
found this Kaya in the can at the Asian
store and I know it doesn't look very
appetizing but believe me it tastes so
good the it's basically a sweet coconut
gem spread for my drink I made tataric
which is like a milk tea the way to mix
it in Malaysia is by pouring between two
cups this allows a lot of bubbles to
form but I'm just going to Stir It
[Music]